not in use due to ongoing Works
therefore the fire exits are through the
main doors of the hall or the stall room
adjacent to the stage
the fire assembly point is the
roundabout stroke island in the front of
the main entrance of the building
please do not delay your evacuation to
collect any belongings
please do not return to the building
until given permission to do so by
Council staff
please note that the meeting will be
audio recorded
would you please switch off your mobiles
or turn them to silent
uh toilets and hand washing facilities
are available in the foyer area
there are no members of the public here
so I'll skip over that
um
members there was a need to use
microphones during the meeting when I
invite you to speak please wait until
there is a microphone in front of you
before speaking as the microphones are
needed for the hearing Loop and for the
audio recording
these are all switched on and ready for
you to speak so you don't need to adjust
them
please make sure that the microphone is
close to your mouth before speaking and
please speak clearly
members voting will be done on a show of
hands in line with the Constitution I
will ask for a show of hands for and
then against recommendations and will
also ask for a show of hands for those
wishing to abstain from voting
so moving on to the agenda agenda item
one apologies for absence we've received
apologies from Council James Gooding and
councilor Julie Gooding are there any
other apologies members
thank you
agenda item two substitute members we
have councilor Mike Steptoe substituting
for councilor James Gooding and
councilor Ian Foster for councilor Julia
Gooding so welcome
uh agenda item three non-members
attending we have councilor Simon
Woodson councilor Cheryl Rowe and
councilor Dave spering so welcome to you
oh sorry and councilor Daniel belting
the style of the show
um a gender sorry a gender item four
minutes of the meeting held on the 1st
of December 2022 are the minutes agreed
members
okay thank you I'll sign those off
a gender item five to receive
Declarations of Interest are there any
Declarations of Interest Council
steptime
yes chairman just as a member of Essex
County Council and also a member of
Barling Parish Council thank you that's
noted
agenda item six is the sustainability
strategy um before I invite councilor
Danielle Belton the portfolio holder for
finance economy and strategy Marcus
hotton the director of environment to
introduce the report can I just let you
know the drill that we'll be going
through
as we go through the report if we are
going to make recommendations as a
committee can you please make them as
clear and unambiguous as possible
what we'll then do is that officers will
then type those up for us we'll take a
short break and we've got the screen
behind us so we can use that then to
finalize the recommendations and then
take a vote on it so as long as
everyone's clear with that so could I
invite councilor Danielle Belton to
introduce the report please
okay
and bear with me I'm just getting my
voice back after a few weeks I'll keep
it relatively brief and the report
presents the updated version of the
draft sustainability strategy
um following on from the meeting in June
of the executive it was agreed that we
would go out to consultation consider
feedback and alter the strategy as
required
so the strategy outlines the aims to
achieve our own ambitious 2030 internal
carbon neutral Target and also the
district-wide 2040 Target and you'll see
from within the report the survey that
went out had the best part of 3 000
responses which is fantastic and shows
that I think this is an item that people
do care about
um the strategy includes kpis something
that I think everybody felt was
important that we can measure successes
and that they they are understandably
measurable as opposed to just words
there's clear objectives and aims
there's an ambition to continue to
engage with stakeholders and experts
it's important that we do engage with
the experts on some of the items
and that we look to make the climate and
sustainability officer a a permanent
position and we have an interim on at
the moment doing some good work but I
think what I hope members that will
agree on reading the strategy that to
achieve some of the ambition and some of
the the challenges that we're going to
face we need a dedicated officer to make
some of this happen
um I trust everybody's read the report
and the strategy so I'll leave it there
for now and and Marcus and I'm sure be
happy to answer questions
okay thank you members has anyone got
any questions counselor AIDS
thank you chair um just a very uh quick
one um selfishly uh I'm looking at the
report and not seeing anything regarding
the motion that actually came to council
uh last time around regarding hydrogen
and encouraging businesses to take that
up so I'd like to see that included at
some point please thank you
thank you any other members we should
cancel the sharp
thank you chairman um I don't know
whether yes I'm getting ahead of myself
but uh
given that there is a recommendation for
one permanent employee over Brentwood
and South End is it therefore
um necessary to harmonize the
sustainability aims of the two regions
thank you
councilor Belton
um to clarify Brentwood and Rochford I
think you you mean
but yeah okay
um
we have to take our own strategy forward
we have our own targets and Ambitions
and they are aside from Brentwood I'm
sure Marcus will talk about the the
harmonization but we've got a shared
sustainability officer at the moment
um that could be under review things may
change in the future if we felt that we
needed someone full-time but at this
point the aim is to have one that we can
that can take a lot of these aims and
goals forward
um I'll let Marcus speak on the the
shared View and the harmonization but
certainly
my my concern is that this committee's
main priority should be about what
Rochford can achieve and need to achieve
for the targets that we set for 20 30
and 2040.
you want to amplify that please
are we there right thank you
um so on that note yes I think this is a
curing of the resource for the post is
the important part of this stage so
whether that's a shared post or it's two
separate posts is something we'll
reflect on it's likely to be a shared
post across the two authorities but at
this stage we just want to cons you know
what I want to do is essentially there
is
um within the budget resource set aside
something that's permanent I think
that's the key thing at this stage in
terms of aims and Ambitions they are
quite similar because I think they are
across all authorities you know it's a
global meta so many of the solutions are
the same regardless of where you are so
yes we can it's a jumping ahead I would
expect here to be a shared resource
because it can
really solve both aims and sort of the
actions for both authorities at the same
time so there should be some
efficiencies there I think just just um
going back to councilor Eaves
um no I think we already discussed it
previously that that's that's my
oversight I apologize I I I do intend to
put the um sort of mention of hydrogen
within there it was just an oversight at
the time in terms of insurance was out
in time for publication for this thank
you
thank you Council Steptoe
yes thank you chairman
um as a substitute member here I've I've
been through the report as best I can in
the time that I've had uh but I've got a
couple of questions really around
electric vehicles
uh one of the things that a number of
residents have contacted me on is that
if somebody lives in say a terraced
house and has no off street parking
how do they go about
recharging their car
where do they do that and second is of
course moving forward
how much work has been done with the
planning department in bringing that
into line with new planning applications
making sure that the requirements for
things like electric vehicles and what
have you are in place
thank you
um I think it's a topic in itself
accounts of zepto so but it's um
obviously it is within the in terms of
that we're talking about electric
vehicle strategy
um and I think that recognizes that that
um not one size fits all so I'm feeling
so in terms of how we approach this it
needs a strategic approach in terms of
EV charges
um some public some private and and
obviously there are options where you
see lamp posts being used uh for off
Street on street parking um so there are
a few to considerable but it's it's
something we'd obviously do in
partnership with with Essex highways but
and then feed that into the sort of
local plan review in terms of policy
thank you
thank you councilor Milton
what oh it's good it's on
um yeah my question is about the there's
recent developments and suggestions with
the um
the the bill to or the Privacy to
improve Energy Efficiency and slash
bills and it has been suggested that
coastal areas particularly where we make
arrangements for energy to come on shore
now that the government is releasing
perhaps more sections of the sea and we
are a Coastal Community near London
um the opportunity may arise for free
bills or reduced bills for residents and
businesses in this area now if we can
include some research into this
and some suggestions the government we
are interested in it
and we may benefit from that and that in
turn with low bills and
lower burning of gas would help improve
air quality from that point of view plus
of course the
the benefits to the residents and
businesses as well so I would like that
to be
looked at to be included in our plan as
it were to see how far we can go there
thank you thank you
thank you I'll make a note of that and
adjust accordingly thank you
Council Belton and if I might just come
back on councilor steptoe's point about
planning so I don't think we covered
that
um I think the reality is it's planning
policy needs to catch up with the
climate strategy
um and that's like a nationwide issue we
need to get these two important
um areas much more aligned so that it's
working in harmony But ultimately it
says in here that we want to maximize
opportunity for renewable we want to we
want to help businesses save money and
be carbon neutral so these are
challenges that the council are going to
face and that's all councils across the
country
um but I don't think it's something we
can necessarily build into the strategy
the climate strategy but certainly
something planning policy hopefully
we'll look at in the future so that the
two things work together
thank you any other members
indicating to speak
Council constable
hello yep
um I was just wondering how the new
committee that is being proposed will
actually work and what powers it will
have or will it be just like this
committee can make recommendations back
to the executive how is this proposed to
workplace
well
um because the there were some
correspondence I've seen between council
Mrs Mason and yourself and councilor Mr
Newport and yourself as well about the
function of the government
um and I wasn't clear about whether this
was reporting to council or to the
executive but I've seen subsequence
correspondence but if you could bring
the two in together
so it's proposed that the um committee
subcommittee would report into the
executive with
um so it is basically overseeing an
executive function uh and and providing
an additional scrutiny and tracking of
that so it wouldn't
um make decisions as such would make
recommendations to the executive but
it's um I think I'm a reflection that
we've obviously tried a member working
group previously in a sense of my
experience this would just provide a
little bit more formality to the to the
sort of um
incentively a committee and it will then
have a bit more sort of a transparency
and scrutiny and it'll be a public set
of minutes and it'll be supported by
additional resource to do so I think
someone's the member working group
series a risk or saying more risk of
slippage but you know you know you've
got some more formality to the committee
but it doesn't make decisions per se it
would just make recommendations to the
executive
but you know um the the sort of the
level of
um frequency of meetings is something
that can be discussed now decided by the
recommendation we put forward but it
will be decided by the executive
and my understanding is that if it's not
all if it's sorry if it's a working
group there are no minutes that are
published so members of the public and
councilors wouldn't see it so the
benefit of having a committee is that
that would be freely available to
everyone
okay uh Council leaves a guy
uh thank you for your Indulgence um when
I was reading the uh doing and throwing
on the setting up of this committee
am I right in reading that the committee
is going to be formed
by a vote from this committee
can you just clarify that for us because
it did read as though it was going to be
formed by a vote from this committee
no it can be a recommendation from this
committee as to how we'd like to see
that structured but the decision would
be an executive decision to make
so you know this isn't a decision making
um body so what we do is you know we can
discuss all the frequency and how we'd
like to see whether um if that's a cross
party
um sort of committee and the sort of
makeup of that committee to suggest to
Executives to consider but it's not for
us to make that decision here
sorry is that not something that should
be for full Council not executive
I think my understanding is because it
couldn't be a committee of the executive
they would effectively own it and we
would be making a recommendation to them
but
okay yeah
okay I come in there counselor
it's okay to come back
so
the sustainability strategy is
um an executive role
however the point of having the
committee is as Marcus alluded to was to
give this whole topic some more weight
and some more Dimension I certainly
would be pushing for a cross-party
committee in exactly the same format
that all of our other committees are set
So Pro rata cross party with a chair
that's voted in by that committee that's
that's how I would like to see it set
and that's what I will personally put
forward at the exec following on for
many recommendations that are made
multiple members of this Council on all
parties groups have lots of people have
expressed the desire for a climate
committee because there is such a lot of
work to do there's a lot of people that
are extremely passionate and I fully
support that the working group done some
amazing work to get us this far the
carbon neutral working group and they
put some great policies forward and got
the 2030
um Target push through but that
essentially isn't happening now and I
think it's to step it up to a committee
and that would be my hope that we we can
get there
okay thanks the can I sort of come back
to you on that about the composition I
understand about the cross party and
pro-rata what what size membership do
you think it would be what are you
thinking of
that that is a decision for the exec
this committee can make a recommendation
as I understand it so if people have a
view on that that can go in as a
recommendation essentially and the exec
will will have a have a vote on that or
a final say but ultimately I think this
is about inclusivity engagement working
together accountability and a way that
we can really measure success that is in
the public domain and so they can hold
us to account and they can attend
meetings if they wish the same as any
other committee okay thanks can I just
throw open to members for discussion
what what sort of size accounts the
constable
yeah I'm just um reading uh page 6.5 4.4
which talks about the climate and
sustainability subcommittee is so if
that's if it's a subcommittee of this
group then it would report to this group
if it's a subcommittee the executive
does it report to the executive
what exactly is it going to do please
Committee of the executive it's coming
to this group as as part of the ons um
report but it's it would be a
subcommittee of the executive
and again sorry just to jump in because
I've been sort of reading through the
the Constitution and the sort of legal
framework but my understanding is that
normally you'd have a subcommittee that
is a the reports to a committee but the
executive isn't actually a committee
technically so this would be a committee
rather than a subcommittee because that
sorry I've had that conversation with
Andrew hunke as honking asking
um who egg subcommittees committees have
the exact same
um
rules and Powers so the wording of it
sort of is none and void but I agree I
would prefer it to be called a committee
I think it's clearer and we all know
where we stand and we're used to working
in in the committee function
yeah absolutely thanks uh cancer
steptime
thank you chairman you partly picked up
on my question there in terms of the
numbers
um I'm I'm pretty sure that this
committee could recommend uh to the
executive what they'd like to see in
terms of the numbers of the committee
um also as well terms of reference it
does give the
um the basis of terms of reference on
the uh subcommittee I think it's on page
6.5 4.4
I would assume that this committee can
make recommendations to either remove or
to add to those terms of reference as
well
yeah okay thank you
um
council Mrs McPherson
thank you chairman um I do have some
questions on the paper but as we're
talking at the moment around um uh the
recommendations
um I would
um propose that we amend a
recommendation number three
to read that a climate and
sustainability committee
is established and my thoughts members
is on the makeup being of seven people
yep okay
yeah I'd actually prefer it to be a
larger committee and the reason being
pro rata
this committee will eventually probably
be quite highly finance committee as we
get towards
you know carbon neutral all the other
things that come out of this and it will
be looked at probably by scrutiny and
all that and everything else I mean and
and as it's such a thing that's going to
affect the lives of almost everybody in
this in this District what it will do
it's an important thing and with the
executive having that
um I know you can have it as an off
branch of some other committee but I
prefer it to be larger rather than
smaller because it's more sustainable if
you excuse the word
it's got more resilience and and of
course it's a very important area so we
we're putting a marker down to say that
we are you know really keen on this and
we're and we wish to take this very very
seriously because at the moment it's
going to be much of a talking shop and a
planning the ways ahead and gain
strategies but eventually it's probably
going to be quite quite quite something
so I think we really should take it
seriously so perhaps a bit more than
seven you know it's only my suggestion
okay to have a figure in mind as a
proposed that as an amendment sorry as
an amendment yeah
councilor Reeves
would it help the committee uh if we
knew what the minimum amount of members
would be if we had representation
proportionally
from every uh every party involved in
the in the council
I don't know what the minimum amount of
people that would indicate that would be
thank you
so just to kind of because you're
thinking about representation from the
difference from all parties yes as we
get uh
basically uh the ideas come from all
directions
right
yeah it would be nine members
suggest nine members
are you happy tremendous
so
German how does that I think what
council agents suggesting is and correct
me if I'm wrong councilories is that at
least one member from each political
group
how does that when work with the pro
router requirement
sorry some
[Applause]
it would be a committee of 1100 right
yeah a committee of 11 to represent all
parties
so
are you happy to amend it to 11.
yeah okay so that's the recommendation
will be it'll be on a pro-rata basis 11
members to make sure that we've got
representation from across all parties
yeah so are you happy to go for a vote
on that recommendation or do you want to
wait until it's
I'll go back on it so it's a committee
of 11 people 11 members
on a pro-rata basis to ensure that
there's representation from each of the
political groups
have I got a second I'll move that from
the chair second the council Mrs Gadsden
those in favor
those against
I was at unanimous sorry I didn't see
your Hangout
sorry
that's all right yeah those have stayed
in
yep so we've got one abstention okay
thank you for that recommendation
um
councilor Foster
of one
okay
okay council Mrs McPherson
thank you chairman um if I can go back
to the papers I've got a couple of um
questions
um it's regarding the key performance
indicators um page 6.28 to 6.31 I wonder
if the portfolio holder or the officer
can explain within that well first of
all there is a typo I think because on
the very first page 6.28 and the risk it
has
um the carbon
it actually says car climate carbon in
Brackets thereafter it actually says
climate carbon impact but my question is
how has that risk been assessed please
that's the quick first question
um the second question is
um also in relation to the action plan
the
um
partner action it actually lists some of
our partners
so we are going to be relying on their
engagement
in delivering our strategy
so are there plans in sync with ours
and what is the impact and risk on our
strategy if it isn't thank you
thank you so could you repeat the first
um I was looking to see which page of
course I can um okay so from page 6.26
to 6.31 there is one two third column
along which is the climate carbon impact
okay it has low medium even high
so presuming that somebody has assessed
these risks and determines them to be
medium low or high could you tell me how
they were assessed thank you
sorry I think we'll we'll clarify that
as a table it's not the risk it's it's
the opportunity
so you know there's a there's a high
opportunity to reduce there's a it's the
impacts in terms of failure to deliver
but actually it's about the the size of
the of the prize if that makes sense so
we'll uh we'll reflect on the wording
there to make that clearer thank you
um on the second question um as part of
the consultation there was a sort of
stakeholder workshops with Partners so
um we've ensured that our policies do
align with their policies so we are
minimizing that risk brilliant thank you
very much
um
I'd like to propose some changes to the
text and the report
at paragraph 4.4 on page 6.5
and
um paragraph 7.1 on 6.5 we mentioned the
word subcommittee and I propose that we
change that to committee
I'll move that from the chair yep second
okay thank you those in favor of making
the amendment
okay
any against
any abstentions
okay thank you
um in the same Vein on page 6.6
um paragraph 9.1
um it says that it's proposed that the
committee recommends the council but in
the light of discussions I believe that
should be executive
so I've moved that from the chair any
one second council Mrs Gadson thank you
those in favor of making that Amendment
those against
any abstentions
okay one Obsession thank you
the
one of one of the things that was
suggested that we would be looking at is
the reporting to the executive so we
will make a recommendation on that
um
personally I I'm in favor of quarterly
reports and the reason why I'm in favor
of quarterly reporting is if you let go
on too long if you get any slippage in
the the work plan
you only pick it up once a quarter
whereas if you're reporting on a
quarterly basis you've only got 12 weeks
that you can slip by
um so I've what do members think of that
cancer Steptoe
chairman I wanted to speak on a slightly
different issue so I'll come back to you
okay thanks so members
I'm I'm proposing from the chair that
the committee reports to the executive
on a quarterly basis of providing a
highlight report
yes does that mean
are you saying that you want the
committee to meet quarterly
if it's going to report quarterly are
you saying you want the committee to
meet quarterly yeah thank you
our second job proposal okay so members
the the
uh recommendation from our committee to
the executive is that the uh the
sustainability committee meets on a
quarterly basis so those in favor
those against
any abstentions
okay thank you that's through
um
I think that was all of the
recommendations that I had there's any
other members got any further
recommendations Council steptime yes
thank you chairman I wanted to pick up
on the terms of reference uh 4.4 on page
6.5
um the second item there it says provide
Direction on emerging opportunities I'd
like to to perhaps try and expand on
that a little bit to to further
understand that because there's an awful
lot of bodies out there that are doing
an awful lot of good work around these
um how that is going to dovetail into
the work that Rochford then does so
perhaps we need to put in their
opportunities
talking to other
organizations
obviously mentioned workshops
Etc how that could be expanded just to
clarify that point
so would
I'm not going to put words into a map
but would just with other
other organizations
I think that would expand it a little
bit but it's understanding what is meant
by merging opportunities I don't fully
understand what that means how that is
going to work you know without looking
and talking to other bodies okay thanks
Mr Hutton
so there are a lot of opportunities in
this sector working with others um as
Mark has mentioned we've worked with
stakeholders such as
um Bayes the energy saving trusts the
Net Zero group and Essex County Council
climate action I think there's been
there's been lots of groups that have
been involved in stakeholders involved
we certainly don't want to have a
committee trying to reinvent the wheel
when there's good work already going on
I think the purpose is to be making sure
that we're looking at those
opportunities engaging with those
stakeholders which is detailed as one of
the aims within the strategies to engage
in those stakeholder conversations so I
think it's just it's kept I think
purposely vague because it captures so
many different items there's going to be
internal opportunities District specific
opportunities and then there's certainly
going to be much wider opportunities
working with third parties
thank you thank you chairman that gives
me a better understanding of that so
leave it alone I'd leave it alone to
that and I've I've been past a better
suggestion as well not not than your
suggestion
um but to Horizon scan for emerging
opportunities with or without other
organizations
so okay from the chair I'll move that
secondary Council steps are those in
favor I'll read it again to Horizon scan
for emerging opportunities with or
without other organizations those in
favor
thank you
those against
any abstentions
okay thank you that is a recommendation
councilor Mrs Gadsden
is that all oh yeah sorry I think you've
sort of reworded it anyway I was only
going to make a suggestion that we um
the word didn't be to investigate and
provide Direction on emerging
opportunities but I think you've covered
that in what you've said okay thank you
any member wishing to speak further
okay
okay no one's indicating so we've got
um
three recommendations sorry the
recommendations in the report are first
of all to report to Executive which is
the change of wording that we've added
in
that the sustainability strategy as
appended is approved and adopted
sorry
talk to me
yeah okay so it should the wording
should be recommended to Executives
subject to the additions that we have
agreed at this meeting so the first
recommendation is that the
sustainability strategy as appended is
approved and adopted
so
I'll move that those in favor
okay thank you that's unanimous
the second recommendation is that the
climate and sustainability officer post
is made permanent those in favor
thank you that's unanimous
and that a climate and sustainability
committee is established as
oh sorry of 11 people
on a pro raster basis to ensure that
there is representation from all
political groups
those in favor
is against
okay any abstentions any extensions
you're not doing it in um
Style with eyes on it I I didn't see
your hand that was all
oh no sir no it's all right no worries
okay so that item is now complete thank
you members
so when we move on now to
um
agenda
item uh
seven which is the key decisions
document
members are there any observations
questions or suggestions on the key
decisions document
okay yeah no one's indicating but we
will when we talk about the work plan
you'll note that the in February we've
got the mill arts and Event Center
update and also
[Music]
um
the report on the community engagement
as well so we'll bring that up under the
work plan
I'm sorry Community investment
okay which brings us now on to agenda
item eight which is our work plan and
apologies to members but um we've
because of a number of reports have been
provided late or later than the plan was
indicating what we've now got is almost
fixture congestion so the meeting that
we've got in February you'll see that
we've got the treasury management
strategy and we must
um
just oh we must move that report because
it goes to Council in February so
there's no way that we can't do that
we've also got the update on the mill
and event center and the community
investment plan and we need to get those
in in February as well
I believe that both of those will be
quite meaty topics and reports I believe
there will be lots of Interest not just
from members but possibly for members of
the public as well so what I've decided
to do in consultation with the vice
chair and officers is take some of those
pieces of work that were in the first of
February so the South Essex parking
partnership and we have an extra meeting
in February on the 23rd of February
to to do that because otherwise we're
going to end up in a situation where we
run out of time and I'm determined to do
justice to the um the update on the mill
and yeah Council Newport
thank you chairman um who have we got
coming in for for the South Essex
parking partnership update please and is
there and who are we to put questions to
prior to if there's anything we want
from that yeah and what we'll do is
we'll
we will write out for that it's only
this week that we had them confirmed the
problem with changing the schedule is
when you get these outside bodies coming
in it's to make sure that they are
actually available when we need them but
yeah set will be coming in so yeah any
questions or any uh anything that you
want to ask bring that up then
yeah and we will have the pre-make for
that
okay
then going forward we've got
um if you look on items to be scheduled
one of them is the Gypsy and travelers
policy an application of evidence we've
actually got the information available
so what we would do is we would share
that report on the 23rd of February as
well so we'll plan to do that
um and the
what I'm hoping for is the planning and
process procedures that would be on the
23rd of February as well okay
first of March we've got the community
safety partnership we've got the firearm
Police Services coming in uh represented
again we would need to feed into them
the lines of inquire no pun intended but
the lines of inquiry that we want to
investigate on this
um but I would just remind members that
it's at a strategic level when we do
this so
um and it's probably the first time in
certainly I can remember that we've had
representatives from those those
organizations so I want to make the most
of it
yeah yeah it's actually the police and
crime and Fire Commission that will be
attending as well so uh
if you don't ask you don't get so we've
asked and he will be attending okay
um
so and then finally on the 4th of April
it's the annual report and that's a
relatively light agenda but we want to
keep it that way because if anything
else slips at least we've got the
flexibility to bring it on to that
agenda as it as it's quite light
so
before I finish on the over the plan has
anyone got any
observations or comments on the work
plan
so yeah councilor Mr Newport
chairman you know
um you know the one item that I'll ask
you about that's missing from the
work plan which is the cost of living
scrutiny work as well oh sorry I've got
that damage yeah I've asked for the
report on that as well so is that going
to be
put on the items to be scheduled or is
it going to be put into the work plan I
think we can put it into the work plan
and it'll either be the 23rd of February
or we'll do it on the 4th of April
23rd of February yep
okay sorry not the 23rd yeah it's the
April one so the cost of living will be
on the April report
okay
and and just very quickly well because
you mentioned it now the um there was a
report that goes to the executive on the
cost of living
um is is it something more that you
expect or
do you discuss this and I'll take it off
yeah with you then okay yeah okay all
right thank you so that is the fine
light and I'd just like to remind people
that um what we'll do is it was a little
bit unfortunate because of the Christmas
break and timings about having the
pre-me that the pre-meat dates will be
circulated well in advance now so we've
got we've got a system going where we
can have the meetings and book them in
and as always if you can't attend in
person if you can
um forward me or phone me with any
questions or observations or
recommendations so
oh yeah sorry yep and uh the vice chairs
just reminded if if you are substituting
or if you have to have a substitute
please try and make sure if it's at all
possible that you're able to brief them
up so that they can turn up knowing
what's going on
okay
right thank you very much members so the
meeting is closed at 2016 hours
[Music]